here is un's secretary for Global
Communications Melissa Fleming she's at
the world economic Forum Summit and uh
yeah apparently they own science and uh
they're gonna stifle the hell out of
everyone else
you know we partnered with Google for
example if you Google climate change
you will at the top of your search you
will get all kinds of un resources
we started this partnership when we were
shocked to see that when we'd Googled
climate change we were getting
incredibly distorted information right
at the top so we we're becoming much
more proactive you know we own the
science and we think that the world you
know should know it and and the
platforms themselves also do
um but again it's it's it is um it's
it's a huge huge challenge that I think
all sectors of society need to be very
active in
we own the science that is what the
communications director at a world
economic Forum event just said we own
the science much like when fauci said if
you attack me you're attacking science
much like uh when Emperor Palpatine said
I am the Senate these are the bad guys
people know it know that they're lying
oh and then what do they do not only do
they own the science but then they work
with Google so that when you Google
something the information you get is not
say an open
an open series of articles based in fact
but they're what they want you to see
okay that is what they are doing and
they're doing it right in front of us so
that they can manipulate you however
however if you're watching this thing on
YouTube right now they can put
recommended videos to send you in a
completely other direction right when
you Google something they're telling you
hey we at the world of economic Forum we
worked with Google to reorganize search
results all of it it's all right there
guys like putting the pieces together is
tough but it's all right there so let's
go full circle here because there are
liars like Joy Reed there are racists
like Kamala Harris there are Bad actors
like this woman from the world economic
forum and their giant tech companies
organizing all of this information to to
basically make you nothing other than
just some blob who will agree with
everything they say as they take away
all of your rights